hi i'm dylan sprouse i play trevor and
after we collided which is coming soon
to
us theaters and today i'm going to be
taking a buzzfeed quiz
on which sprout stream i really am maybe
maybe what my soul
[Music]
is
first things first pick another set of
iconic twins to hang with
mary kate and ashley olsen tian tamera
mowry
joel and benji madden aaron and sean
ashmore
i think i would go with tia and tamara
i've
met them and they just seemed like a
blast to hang out with so
those are the two obviously select the
disney series dvd to bring with you to a
deserted island the sweet life of zach
and cody
wizards of waverly place hannah montana
and that's so raven
hmm wow that's tough i think i would
probably i know it sounds
silly to say but i think i would
actually do the sweet life only because
if i was
on a deserted island it would uh it
would fill me with joy to see
my friends and family in those episodes
together
it would remind me to keep on hanging in
there in the deserted island
choose a sprouse roll you know for
funsies
julian mcgrath from big daddy nick from
banana split
billy or bobby from that 70 show trevor
from after we collided
ben geller from friends will newman from
five feet apart
hmm who would i choose that's a good one
i would do julian mcgrath from big daddy
a lot of fun memories there i get to
relive my six-year-old experience in new
york for the first time
that would be fun that looks like cole
there you can always tell because he's
got very large
uh two front teeth uh my teeth since i
was a rowdy little lad
were uh chipped in places and uh and it
was very scrappy
that's definitely cold there look at his
angelic little smile
wow what an angel choose a dynamic duo
to snack on
peanut butter and jelly bacon and eggs
spaghetti and meatballs
cheese and crackers i'm a big pb and j
guy
it's my favorite it's either between
that or the blt
so i'm gonna do peanut butter and jelly
and i'm gonna do like one of those
artisanal
thick peanut butters and a nice
strawberry jelly
and then i cut the crust off because i'm
an artist
and uh and i'll eat that on potato bread
pick a tipton
regular to live with mr mosby london
tipton
maddie fitzpatrick arwen hawkhouser
oh my gosh geez i love the photos that
you picked for this too
if i had to pick a regular to live with
i'd pick london tipton i mean she's got
the run of the tipton hotel
so i'd either do that or i would pick
arwen hawkhauser because arwen
uh in the show always was making these
really cool
gadgets that we would play around with
so uh so it's one of those two
i picked arwen pick a hobby to take up
in your 20s
narrative podcasting polaroid
photography brewing artisanal alcohols
writing comic books wow i don't know
that's tough
i would probably say grooming artisanal
alcohols that just sounds like something
a wizard would do
finally choose a riverdale plotline that
sounds fake but it's totally real
ugh colin would love this when betty
found out she had serial killer gene
when archie got mauled by a bear when
jughead delivered his i'm a weirdo
speech out of the blue
when cheryl waterboarded her mother with
maple syrup
oh god when edgar ever never and his
organ harvesting fork joined the fold
when veronica rounded underground speak
easy
well i was actually in vancouver when
archie got mauled by a bear it was
really funny to be there for that
but when cheryl water waterboarded her
mother with maple syrup is the most
extremely bizarre thing i've ever read
so i think i'm going to pick that one
i got dylan sprouse you're the older
wiser and dare i say more dashing twin
ooh
stop you're mellow and a bit mysterious
but that just draws people closer
closer into your orbit wow okay i gotta
say that was a really nice little blurb
at the end there i think you're giving
me a little too much credit but i'll
take it i guess on the inside i
am actually dylan what a lovely quiz
[Music]
you